Hey everyone, welcome back to the
channel. We're back with popular demand
for another low-level design breakdown
today. So, we're going to be breaking
down another really popular LLD
interview question, this time designing
an elevator system. This is one that
comes up a lot at Microsoft in
particular. Shows up across the big
fangs that do LLD interviews, and it's a
step up from the beginner problem that
we already broke down with Connect 4,
because there's some really complicated
movement logic that has some significant
depth to it.
Uh I'm going to walk through how I would
answer this as an interviewer, and also
what I, as the interviewer, will be
looking for at each step along the way.
Uh just really quickly, for those of you
who are new here, I'm Evan. I'm a former
Meta staff engineer, and I'm the current
co-founder of hellointerview.com.
Hello Interview is a platform that helps
software engineers, just like you,
prepare for their upcoming interviews.
So, we have everything you need,
including in-depth content on different
interview types, such as system design,
ML system design, low-level design,
code, behavioral, AI coding, you name
it, we probably have it, uh as well as
in-depth guided practices that let you
walk through these problems, like the
one we're showing you today,
step-by-step yourself, and finally, mock
interviews with senior plus and managers
from your target company. So, all this
to say, if you're preparing for software
engineering interviews, come on over to
hellointerview.com after this video,
check us out. The overwhelming majority
of the content there is totally free.
Uh what else?
If you like what we're doing here,
consider liking and subscribing. I
always forget to say that one, so I'll
throw that one in there. And then the
last thing is, as you can see on the
screen here, if videos aren't your
thing, we have a full written breakdown
of this problem, as well as many others,
on the site. So, you can head over here
and go through this instead, if you
would prefer.
Before we dive in, let's just quickly
touch on the framework that we're going
to follow both in this YouTube video, as
well as the framework that I suggest you
use for all of your upcoming low-level
design interviews. And the goal of of
this framework, or any framework really,
is to keep you focused in on track,
while ensuring that you touch on all of
the most important things, and don't end
up running out of time in what is a
short interview typically.
So, the first step in any low-level
design interview is to cover the
requirements. You're going to spend some
time here engaging in a back-and-forth
with your interviewer in order to
understand exactly what it is that
you're building, and have an agreed-upon
set of requirements that's going to take
you forward.
From there, you want to model the
entities and their relationships. This
is basically asking, like, what are the
nouns of my system? What are the things
that I'm going to want to model as
classes or enums moving forward?
And then with those in hand, you can
move on to your class design in order to
take those entities, go through them one
by one, using your requirements, to
derive both the state and the behavior
for each one of your entities or each
one of your classes. And then in this
case, state is just the things that you
need to remember in order to enforce the
the requirements,
and the behavior is what the class needs
to be able to do, basically, the
functions. You're kind of creating the
interface for the code.
And then you can move on to number four.
Well, with that class design in hand, we
need to actually go implement it. And
so, this is different by each company
and each region. Some companies, or the
majority of companies, just prefer
pseudo code here instead of actual code.
They're worried more about your design
choices than your syntax. For this
video, that's what we'll do. We'll focus
on pseudo code and keep it language
agnostic. Um but for the full
implementation, Java, Python,
TypeScript, other languages, they're all
available in the written breakdown
that's going to be linked in the
description. So, if that's what you're
after, go check that out there.
And then finally, in your low-level
design interview, if time permits, you
tackle extensibility. And so, these are
just follow-up questions about how the
design could evolve.
Uh I'll cover what some of the most
popular ones are for this particular
question as we get to the end.
All right, enough with all the setup.
Let's let's jump in. So, imagine that
you sat down in your low-level design
interview, and you were greeted with
this prompt on the shared editor. Design
an elevator control system for a
building. The system should handle
multiple elevators, floor requests, and
move elevators efficiently to service
those requests. Great. So, some of you
may be thinking, I know how elevators
work. I've taken elevators. This is
easy. Let me just jump in. Let me start
coding. Let me get working on the
problem. Um and let me encourage you not
to do that. The interviewer wants you to
ask clarifying questions in order to
clarify things up front. This problem
statement is intentionally vague. And
so, problem analysis is the competency
that interviewers are explicitly
evaluating and grading you on in order
to make sure that you can take a moment,
understand the problem, and nail down
those core requirements. And so, that's
what we're going to do here today. We're
going to ask some questions first to
better understand that. Now, I tend to
ask my questions, cuz it's a question
candidates always ask me, how do I know
what questions to ask? And I break them
into three categories. You want to ask
about primary capab- capabilities, cuz
you're going to have to watch me type
here in real time, error handling, and
then scope boundaries.
And so, what are the main functions of
the system, the primary capabilities?
What are the error handling that we need
to consider? And then what's in and out
of scope for our particular system?
And so, if you were going to ask
questions in each of these categories,
I'm going to paste in some questions
here so that you guys don't watch me
just do a bunch of typing.
But your questions might look something
like this. I might first ask my
interviewer, how many elevators and
floors? Are they fixed or are they
configurable? And if I'm the
interviewer, I might respond, let's keep
it simple for now. Let's say there's
three elevators, maybe 10 floors, and
it's fully fixed for the time being.
I might ask then, are hall are hall
calls just up and down, or do they
choose a floor?
And so, to level set on terminology, if
you think about an elevator, there are
two places where you can press buttons.
The first is if you are not currently in
the elevator, you're waiting
on a specific floor, and you can
typically press either up or down,
and this requests the car to come to
you, right? But in some fancy elevators,
you can even specify what floor you want
to go to. And so, that's what this
question is asking. Those are referred
to as hall calls, and what we'll call
them today as hall calls. So, are hall
calls just up and down, or do you get to
choose a floor? And as the interviewer,
I might say, just up and down, right?
You just choose the direction from the
hall call.
Uh then I might ask, can passengers
select multiple destination floors
inside the elevator? Interviewer would
say, yes. Now, this is normal of
elevators. You get into the elevator,
when you're in the actual elevator cab
itself, you can click any number of
floors. And these are kind of
destination calls, right? They specify
where you want the car to actually go.
Uh and then I might ask, I noticed that
in the problem you said that you want
the cars or the cabs to move
efficiently. What does this mean?
And as the interviewer, I'd probably
stay vague here. I'd say, I'm going to
let you define it, right? You'll be able
to specify what the algorithm is for
determining which direction any of these
specific elevators take in order to
service requests, but we want to do it
in a way that is reasonably efficient.
Okay. So, we'll keep that in mind when
we get designing.
As for error handling, maybe I want to
say things like, what about invalid
floor requests? A little silly,
considering it's hardware and you have
fixed buttons, but we're building
software, so it's a decent question.
Uh as the interviewer, I'd say, yeah,
you know, any request outside of the
zero to nine, the 10 that we
specified, throw an error, reasonable
error of some sort. Um what if someone
requests the floor that we're already
on? It's a no-op, no big deal.
Uh and then some scope boundaries.
Capacity, weight limits, door mechanics,
all of that hardware stuff, emergency
stops. Do we have to handle that? As the
interviewer, I'll say, no, that's out of
scope for now. Maybe we'll talk about it
in extensibility at the end. And then
this last one is is important. So,
whenever you have a mechanical system
like this,
you might want to ask, is this a
simulation where we are simulating time
with steps and ticks,
or are there actual hardware control
software involved here?
And as the interviewer, I would tell
you, nope, let's focus on a simulation.
Steps and ticks.
Um and this is common in these sorts of
interviews. So, a real interview system,
of course, doesn't have a step function
you call to advance time, which is what
we'll use here. It has motor controls,
floor sensors,
uh these fire interrupts, they have
async control flows driven by hardware
events.
But in a low-level design interview,
we're almost always expected to build
the simulation,
uh whether the problem is elevators,
parking lots, vending machines, traffic
lights, right? The pattern's usually the
same. You want to abstract away the
hardware and control time yourself with
a step or a tick. And this keeps the
problem really tractable and allows us
to get through it in 35 minutes. So,
you'll see when we get into the
implementation, but this basically means
that we are going to have some loop that
says step, and that step is going to
increment every elevator by one move,
maybe one floor, maybe open, whatever it
may be. Um and that's how we're going to
manage the processing of time.
Cool.
Um so, once you've asked all of these
questions, then you have a pretty good
understanding. You were probably taking
notes throughout. Maybe I should have
done so here, but instead, I'm going to
paste in what ends up being a concrete
final set of requirements.
And so, this is the really important
thing that you want to agree upon with
your interviewer before you get going
and actually designing the system. And
so, with our in it with our system,
we're going to agree that the
requirements are that the system manages
three elevators serving 10 floors, zero
to nine. Users can request an elevator
from any floor. We call this a hall
call. And the system will decide which
elevator it needs to dispatch to. So,
we'll need to be thinking about an
efficient way to do that.
Once inside, users can select one or
more destination floors.
And then the simulation runs in these
discrete time steps. A step call
advances time, right? That'll click when
you see us actually do it.
Um elevator stops come in two types, as
we had mentioned. This is a useful
distinction. You have those hall calls.
This is a request from a floor, either
up or down. And you have a destination
request. These are requests from inside
an elevator, uh no direction specified.
The system can handle multiple
concurrent pickup requests across
floors, of course.
And then any invalid requests we agreed
should be
uh return false or throw an error.
Requests on the current floor are just a
no-op. So, that's the summary of
everything that we talked about as it
pertains to requirements. I'm going to
look at my interviewer at this point.
I'm going to say, "How's this sound to
you? Anything you would change? Are we
aligned?" They'll give me the thumbs up.
And now I know that I'm going to go
design a system that they were actually
expecting and not waste a bunch of time
designing something that wasn't aligned
with what they wanted.
Now that we have our requirements in
place, the next step in our delivery
framework is to move on to those
entities.
And so the entities are the nouns of our
system. These are the things that we may
consider being classes. They're kind of
setting up what are we going to need to
focus on when we get into class design
in just a moment. And so this actually
an easy process here and it builds
linearly off of the requirements that we
just did.
You scan through your requirements
looking for nouns and you consider
whether each of those nouns makes sense
being a class or maybe just a string or
a number or a value object or something
in your ultimate design.
So if we scroll through here, the first
that we get is we get an elevator.
And so let's talk about an elevator. I
think it's clear to everyone that an
elevator is almost certainly a class in
our system. It needs to maintain state
like the current floor, the direction,
which floor to stop at, the requests
that it needs to serve. And then it
needs to enforce rules like the
directions that it travels, when it
stops, all of these sorts of things. And
so elevator
we know that's almost certainly going to
be a class.
Now if we keep reading here, we land on
floors and requests. Those are nouns
that come up a lot. And so we can put a
floor here.
And at first glass a floors first
glance, excuse me, a floor seems really
important. But what is a floor class if
we build it? What would it actually do?
What state would it maintain?
Uh what rules would it enforce? Right?
And they don't. They don't maintain
state and they don't enforce rules. It's
really just a number. It's just a
property that tells us which floor, what
number the elevator either needs to go
to or is currently on. And so not a
class here. This is just a number. It's
probably going to be a field on things
like requests and elevators.
Now the other one that we mentioned was
request. And so what is a request? A
request we know can be one of two types.
It can be a hall call or it can be a
we'll call it a destination request from
inside of the of the actual elevator
itself.
And this needs to know the floor that
the request is going to if it was from
inside of the elevator. And if it was
from outside the elevator then it needs
to know the direction. Right? Are we
going up or are we going down?
And so in essence it could just be a
value object. It could just be a tuple.
Depending on your language, maybe you
want it to be a class. But we'll put it
class here just for simplicity.
Um but we'll just kind of note to
ourself that we need
direction and potentially the floor.
Those are the things that are
interesting there.
And now there's one other that's maybe
not as explicitly mentioned as a noun in
our requirements. But when we think
about this simulation running discrete
steps, all of this, and we think about
the fact that someone needs to dispatch
hall calls.
And all of this is like maintained by
the elevator system, you could call it.
Or as is commonly named in these sorts
of designs, the controller.
And so we're going to have an ele-
vator controller. This is certainly
going to be a class. The elevator
controller is going to be that thing
that is our main entry point to call
step, which is going to increment time
in our simulation. It's going to be the
thing that receives hall calls and
decides which elevator we need to
dispatch it to. It's our orchestrator,
right? So it owns the system level view
and makes all of the coordination
decisions. Certainly a clear entity in
our system.
Now that we fleshed out our entities, we
can move on to our third step, which is
our class design.
And our class design is where we specify
the state that each class holds and what
operations it supports. And so we're
going to work top-down. We're going to
start with the elevator controller
since it's the entry point. The external
code interacts with the controller, not
the individual elevators. We'll design
the interfaces first, then we'll drill
into the elevator. And this will keep us
focused on just those public contracts
instead of getting bogged down on all
the implementation details, which is
what is going to come next. So
let's get started on doing exactly that.
I'm going to start by designing the as I
said ele- gosh, typing on the spot is
hard. The elevator controller.
And the way that we can determine the
class design is actually super
straightforward. It's again just derived
exclusively from our requirements. And
we just want to answer two questions.
What is the state this class needs to
maintain? And what are the methods,
functions, or behaviors that it needs to
be able to do?
And so if we look up at our
requirements, we can say that the system
manages three elevators serving 10
floors. Okay? So that indicates to us
that we are going to need to have
elevators and that's just going to be a
list of ele-
elevators.
Right? Easy.
As far as state goes on the controller
that's it. Uh requests themselves, we're
going to allow those to be managed by
the elevators. And so when a request
comes in, we're going to dispatch it
immediately to an elevator.
Now you could argue that request should
sit on the controller um and then the
controller decides, maybe based on a
queue of requests, when to send them to
each elevator. There's pros and cons to
both approaches.
I like elevators maintaining their own
state. I think it's clearer um and it
also allows them to make better
scheduling decisions that we'll see
later on.
So as far as the elevator controller
goes, it's going to have one bit of
state and that is just the elevator.
Um but what about the methods? What are
the functions that it needs to be able
to do?
So coming back up to our requirements,
users can request an elevator from any
floor. Those are our our hall calls. All
right? So we should have then a
request
elevator
and that's going to take in a
floor that you're currently on
and a direction that you want to go.
And maybe we just return either a
boolean for success or failure. Maybe we
return void.
Uh and then what else do we have? We
have that simulation runs in discrete
time steps. All right?
And so we know that the elevator
controller is our entry point. It's what
runs those steps. So we'll have step
void. And step you'll see clearly in the
implementation is simply iterating
through Let me make this a little
bigger. It's simply iterating through
each of the elevators and incrementing
their step by one. Um just for
completeness' sake here, we'll add a
constructor as well. This constructor is
what's going to initialize those
elevators with three elevators in our
case that can put into the list. So
there is our complete class design for
the elevator controller. The state is
the elevators and it's got a couple core
functions there.
With that, we can move on then to our
actual elevator.
And so if we move down the stack to I
don't know why elevator is really hard
for me to type, but we can move to
elevator.
And what does an elevator need to know?
Well, elevators are serving those 10
floors. Elevators are serving those 10
floors.
Um so we need to know probably which
is the current floor that this elevator
is actually on. So it's current floor.
Uh we also need to know which direction
it's going. All right?
This direction it's going and I'm going
to create a direction enum.
And so I'm going to have an enum here
for direction
which will have up down. And this part's
a little bit trickier, but I'm going to
throw it in there. We're going to have
idle. A lot of candidates forget this,
but elevators aren't only going up or
down. Sometimes if there are no
requests, they are sitting idle. This is
important. Um it'll have some
consequences in our actual
implementation. So make sure that you're
thinking through all of the possible
states when you're adding an enum. But
I'm going to have up, down, and idle
respectively. And then an elevator as we
had mentioned just a moment ago, it is
going to need to have its set of
requests. So users can select one or
more destination floors we defined up
here and we said that our elevators were
going to have requests. So they are
going to have a set of
requests.
And the reason that I'm going to make it
a set of requests instead of a list is
because this way we'll handle
deduplication for us automatically. So
you may not need to know this during
class design. Maybe you come up with
this in your actual implementation. But
this is great because now if multiple
people click the same floor um it's all
good. All right? We're not going to try
to go to that floor multiple times. That
doesn't make a lot of sense. Um so this
is the complete state for elevator. And
now we need to ask ourself what does
this elevator actually need to be able
to do?
And so I can start with
our simple constructor again.
Get that one out of the way.
Um and then what else do we need?
Well, we need to be able to add
requests, certainly. That's going to
take a
maybe it's just going to take a request
object. All right? It's going to take a
request object. Um and then it can
return either a boolean for success
failure again or void.
Importantly, we need that step function.
All right? So this guy is just going to
call step on all the elevators and
that's going to determine whether we do
a step up, a step down, whether we open
our doors, whether we do all of that. Um
maybe we want to be able to get our
floor, of course. Easy enough.
These are just simple getters. It's
going to return a number or an int I
guess we've defined it as here in our
pseudo code.
And we also want to be able to get our
current direction.
Get our current direction.
And that is going to be that direction
enum.
So if we come up here, like did we miss
anything? What's inside? Users can
select one or more destination floors.
If they do that, that's going to be
added to our set of requests. Okay? No
problem. The simulation runs. That's
going to have the step. Users can
request an elevator from any floor. We
just talked about that as well. That's
the hall calls, and so that'll be
dispatched from here to an add request
call to elevator.
Uh the multiple concurrent pickups is
fine. Our set helps us with
deduplicating there.
All good. Okay. So, I think I feel good.
We might notice we're missing something
as we get down to implementation, but I
think I feel good about how elevator is
looking.
And that means that we should move on to
our next one here, which is request.
Requests is a fun one and one that we
should probably talk about for just a
moment. So, as we already discussed,
requests have two type. So, let's just
specify it.
They have the hall calls.
In a hall call, you specify the floor
that the elevator needs to go to,
and you also specify the direction. So,
floor plus
direction.
Now, destination calls, we'll call them,
these are from inside or destination
requests, these are from inside the
elevator, and they just have a floor.
All right? There's no once you get to
this floor, you have to continue in a
certain direction like is the case for a
hall call.
And so, one way way that you might think
about modeling this is that you just
need a floor, which is required, and
that's going to be the int, and a
direction, which we already have a
direction enum, so why not just use it,
and maybe make it nullable because we
don't always have a direction.
A lot of candidates jump to this.
This isn't horrible. I want to be clear,
it's not horrible, but there are some
issues with it.
The first is that there is uh we're
reusing elevator directions, which have
an idle state, for request. There's no
such thing as an idle request. That
doesn't make sense. So, now by encoding
and using the exact same enum, we've
introduced a state to a request that
can't be possible. So, that's already an
issue, right?
Now, we could add a different enum here
and call it a request direction and have
just up and down, but you still then
have this nullable thing. It's nullable.
And whenever you add null a null here,
you kind of leave the question open for
what does null mean here?
What is the null state? This needs to be
explained by somebody reading the code
for the first time, they don't
necessarily know what this means. And
so, there might be a cleaner way that we
can actually model this. And what I
would suggest is that we take the
following approach. We encode those
states explicitly, and we say that we
have a floor, and then we also have a
request
type.
And that request type is a new enum.
A req-
quest type
is an enum, which is either a pickup
up. So, basically, the pickup in the
direction is up. A pickup down. Those
are both our hall calls. Or a
destination. Okay? So, you have two hall
calls that encode whether they're going
up or down. You have the destination.
And then now, we don't have any
nullable. It's super clear to any
readers what the request types are.
There's three types of requests.
Basically, the two hall calls, a pickup
up and down, and then the car call of
being what or the cab call of being the
destination. And then just for
completeness here, we can have uh
our constructor, which takes in the
floor and the type. We can have
get floor, which is going to return the
floor,
and
get type,
which is going to return
the request type.
Okay? And then importantly, for our set
up here,
equality is going to be need to be based
on the floor and the type. So, a request
of seven
uh floor seven with type pick up pickup
up is different than request of seven
pickup down.
Different elevators would go and service
those differently because the
expectation is that you don't have an
elevator elevator car that comes to you
when you when you chose up from the hall
who's actually going down, right?
Hopefully, that's pretty clear. Okay.
So, if I zoom out a little bit,
there
is our complete class design. We got an
elevator controller, which controls the
elevators. The elevators have a set of
requests that they need to service.
Elevators are moving in a direction,
either up, down, or idle. And requests
can be one of three types, a pickup up,
a pickup down, or a destination.
Here, we got our class design in place,
and so now let's have some fun. Let's
move on to the actual implementation.
This is where we'll implement the actual
method bodies. In our case, we'll do it
in pseudocode, as is the case in in most
low-level design interviews.
And your interviewer at this point will
usually point out the core methods or
the core functions that they actually
want you to implement. You usually don't
have time to write all of the code, so
they're going to point out some
interesting ones, and those are the ones
that you're going to focus on.
If I was conducting this interview, I
would say that like the elevator
controller's request elevator
elevator is interesting, as well as the
elevator step.
And so, we'll do those. We'll also do
some additional ones just for
completeness, so that you guys can see
kind of all of the core functions here.
Note that that'll mean this video
probably goes a lot longer than a real
interview does. Um you guys tend to like
more information than less. Um
let me know if that's no longer the case
in the comments, and we can switch it
up. But I'm going to try to give you
guys all the information you need here.
The way that we go about the
implementation, just like all the other
steps, we have a methodical uh process
to do this. We're going to outline in
English what is the core logic this
function needs to support, and then what
are the edge cases?
And we usually already know that core
logic based on both the combination of
our requirements and our class design,
and same to with those edge cases. So,
we'll just make them explicit. Let me
make things bigger so you guys can see
it.
I'm going to start with that elevator
controller,
and I'm going to start with the
interesting function that we just talked
about, which was to request
ooh,
which is to request the elevator,
and you have the floor that you're
requesting it from, and then you have
the request type, right? That enum that
we defined earlier.
And the way that I'm going to do this,
just like I said, is I'm going to
outline the core logic,
and then I am going to outline the edge
cases.
They are conditions.
And so, what happens when you request an
elevator?
Well, the first thing that you need to
do is that you need to figure out what
is the best elevator for us to send this
request to.
In general, we find an elevator, and
then we add this request to that
elevator's requests.
And you could find the elevator a
handful of different ways.
You could find that elevator maybe by
doing
just finding the closest current
elevator.
You could find the round robin, the the
the elevator that you've uh
it's been the longest since you set a
request.
You can do something a little bit
smarter, what we'll call direction
aware. That's something that we'll
handle. But the general concept is that
we need to
find the best elevator
to handle this request.
And then the second thing is send that
request to the elevator. Pretty
straightforward.
As far as edge cases go,
I guess the only one that we can really
think of is if that floor is out of
bounds. Again, you have physical
buttons, so this is kind of contrived.
Um but we'll throw an error if the
request is going to somewhere other than
floor zero to nine in our case, then
that's not so good.
Um one call that I'll have here is that
our request elevator and our elevator
controller and our elevator class, these
are examples of the design principle
called information expert. You don't
need to remember that name, but the
concept is important. And it's that
elevator owns the requests, so it's
going to be the one that decides whether
or not to stop, whether reverse, or
whether to move. That's what we're going
to handle later on in elevator.step.
Um but the controller owns the list of
elevators, and so it decides which one
to dispatch request to, right? Each
class makes decisions about the data
that it's own it owns. That's the
takeaway here. That's the information
expert, and it's what we're following as
we implement this.
Um okay. So, let's do this. The first
thing is that I am going to create a new
request object out of what just got
passed in. You could say should this
just take a request? Maybe. This is our
external uh public function call, and so
I'm making the argument that a request
is an internal type, so we'll take it
and we'll construct that internal type.
Um but I should learn how to spell or
type correctly.
And then we need to determine that best
elevator.
So, we'll select
best elevator, and it will take that
request.
Uh and then we are just going to return
that best elevator, add its
add the request to its set of requests.
All right? Straightforward. Now, what
you'll see here is that I just kind of
like offloaded all the hard part. You're
like, select best elevator, that was the
interesting bit, and you just totally
skipped it. But this is so effective in
low-level design interviews. I
abstracted out into a private helper
method the complex part, and I'm going
to now go implement it. You guys will
see me implement it, but this helps my
logic be super clean. It helps it map
directly to my core logic and my edge
cases. We haven't taken care of edge
cases, we'll do that in just a second.
Uh and then I can move on to my private
helper without being like bogged down in
the details too early. Hopefully, that's
resonating. Um before I go and implement
that helper though, let's handle this
edge case. So, what did we say? We said
that if floor is less than zero or floor
greater than nine, uh then we'll return
false.
Of course, in reality, these are
probably like a max floor uh min floor
enum. In our contrived requirements,
they were fixed numbers, so we're just
going to use them there.
There's actually one other thing I want
to call out now that I'm just looking at
this.
Um type is a request type, and we said
the request types could be pickup up,
pickup down, and destination.
Clearly though, you can't request an
elevator with a destination type. That
destination type is reserved for when
you press a button within a
a car,
right? So, this is kind of wrong. We're
exposing an an interface to this
function, we're exposing parameters for
which one of the enum states is not
allowed.
Now, in an interview, I would recognize
this, and I would call this out, and I
would say to my interviewer, there are a
handful of ways to adjust this. We could
narrow the type definitions here. So, I
could say that this is just pickup up or
pickup. I'm using kind of a TypeScript
notation here now. I'm just mixing
notations since it's it's pseudo code.
We could validate here at runtime if
type type type equals destination, throw
an error.
destination
You know, throw.
Um I don't love that. I'd rather narrow
the types so that we can do it, you
know,
statically as opposed to at runtime. And
this we said we were going to throw,
right? So, throw.
error
out of bounds
Uh
and clearly maybe I want a better one
there. So,
not a valid floor.
Anyway,
uh so, I'm going to type here. Fine. If
you notice something like that in your
interview, it's okay. You can go back.
You can change class design so you can
be clearer.
Um but there that is.
Now, let's do that select best elevator.
And so, select best elevator here is
going to take in a request. And it's
going to determine which one of these
elevators we should actually end up
uh servicing the request. As I
mentioned, there's different ways that
you could do this. And I may even
mention to my interviewer, this might be
an appropriate place for the strategy
pattern
where you actually have an interface for
selecting the best interface
uh or best elevator, and you can
implement that strategy differently. You
can do it as nearest, load balancing,
direction aware. And then whoever the
caller is or whoever the engineer is can
define, you know, which one of these
strategies they actually want to use for
their current elevator system.
Now, we define that we have a single
elevator system. And so, I'm going to
just implement what I think the best uh
elevator is, and we have a limited
amount of time in an interview, but I
would note that to my interviewer so
they know that I'm aware of patterns,
but I'm not over engineering.
Um okay. So, again here we can do that
core logic and error cases. What is the
core logic for selecting the best in uh
the best elevator?
Well, the first thing that we could do
is we could try to find the elevator
moving towards us.
Are there any that are in our direction
and coming towards us, right? Uh and
going in the right direction.
If none,
maybe we just try the idle elevators
and get the one that's nearest, right?
So, get the nearest idle elevator.
And then three, maybe you know, if any
fall back, then you just
pick the nearest, pick any, whatever,
right? There's some fall back condition
there.
Uh edge cases wise,
let's see as we implement, but nothing's
immediately coming to mind.
Uh so, what does this look like? Best
equals is anybody
uh moving towards me? So, find moving
toward
with the request. And then if there is
somebody moving towards me, basically
this is not null,
then I'm going to return
I'm going to return that guy.
Otherwise, let's say I'm going to find
the nearest idle
to my floor. I'm going to pass in the
floor there.
Uh
and if that guy is not null,
then I'm going to return it.
Otherwise, maybe we just return,
you know, find the nearest.
Find nearest.
So, same strategy we took above. We kind
of offloaded the maybe more interesting
parts, but it makes our logic super
clear, and it allows us to now implement
that interesting part, which will do the
find moving toward cuz it's the one that
is maybe the most difficult, and I don't
want to offload that forever. And so,
I'll push that off to my to my
interviewer. Uh I won't push that off
anymore, I'll say.
And this is the one that I'm going to
implement. So, core logic here.
Find moving toward. What does that mean,
right? That means that something an
elevator is currently going down
and I am lower than it.
Or an elevator is currently going up and
I, being the request, am higher than it,
right? So, this is going to be
uh
you know, scan elevators
going
that direction
and then like keep track of closest.
Return closest.
Something like that. Okay.
So, let's do that. Let's say
the floor
that we are currently on, our request
floor,
is that. Great.
The direction of our request is because
we have different types here, right? We
have get type.
If this equals equals
pick up, up,
then we're going up.
Then we're going up. Otherwise, we're
going down. So, all this is just
converting this into the elevator's term
the elevator's language because we
separated those enums for good reason.
Um but this is saying that if the
request is to pick up up, then we need
this to be going up. We need an elevator
that is going up cuz you again, just to
be super clear here, even if there is an
elevator that is close to my floor five,
if it is currently going down and I
press the up button, I don't want it to
get me. I don't want to get in an
elevator going down, right? So, that's
what this is saying. It's saying that
the direction of this request in
elevator terms is that the elevator must
be going up uh or the elevator must be
going down respectively based on that
ternary, right?
Uh and then let's just set up some state
for our uh loop here.
The current nearest is null.
And then the current min distance that
we're going to iterate over can be, you
know, some max value in whatever your
language is.
And so then it's for E in elevators.
We're going to loop over all of our
elevators here,
and we're going to say if uh
E.get get direction
does not equal the direction that we
need, so you're not going in the right
direction, right? This is an elevator
that is going down when we requested up
or the other way around, then continue
through our loop. We don't want him,
okay? Easy enough.
The second one
is if
the direction equals equals up
and
the elevator's current
or the elevator's get floor, I think we
called it, right? The elevator's floor
is greater than our current floor,
or
the other way around,
it's moving down
and it is less than our floor. So, think
about what that means, right? It means
that yes, this elevator is going the
right direction,
but it's already lower than us or higher
than us respectively. So, like it's
beyond us. It's going down. It's going
the direction we want, for example, but
I'm on floor five and it's on floor
four. It's heading to floor three. It's
not a good candidate for me anymore,
right? So again, we don't want it.
Um if all those things are not the case,
then we can see how far is it from the
floor that we want. So, now we confirmed
that it is coming towards us. And let's
just see how many how far away is it?
And then if that distance is less than
the current minimum distance that we
have, which we set defaulted to max
value, so the first one will certainly
meet this,
then we can update
our min
distance
to that new distance.
And nearest is that elevator.
At the end of all that, we return
nearest.
So, I don't know how valuable that was
for you guys to like watch me code that.
Uh maybe let me know in the comments,
but let's zoom in just for a second to
to take a quick check. All that we're
doing here is iterating through all of
the elevators. If the elevator is going
not in the direction that we want, it's
not interesting to us. If it's going in
the direction we want, but it has
already passed us, it's not interesting
to us. Otherwise, let's see how far it
is from us,
and let's find the one that is the
closest, right? This is going to be the
best possible elevator for us and the
one that we're going to choose. If
that's not the case, then we're just
going to go filter all the ones that are
idle and do the same absolute check,
right? To check which one is closest.
I'm not going to write that code cuz
it's very similar and it's super
straightforward. Um otherwise, a blanket
find nearest can be our fallback. This
is obviously the most straightforward.
This just take all the requests, or
excuse me, take all the elevators, take
their current floor, get the absolute
distance between um the requested floor,
and we're good to go.
Okay. Um
maybe just to be complete here
for request elevator for uh elevator
controller, let me also add step.
Um
this is just so straightforward, but I
think it's worth seeing.
It's just this.
All right. So, each iteration through
our simulation, the elevator controller
calls step, and it's just going to
iterate through all of the elevators and
call step, right? So, this controller,
it doesn't know how elevators moves. It
just calls E.step. The elevator doesn't
know about other elevators. Each class
is hiding its internals. This is the big
one. This is encapsulation
in object
um oriented programming, right?
Now, let's move on to that elevator step
function. This is the big one, the
interesting one. So, we're going to have
our elevator class,
and then we have step. And this is
essentially
how do elevators move? How do they know
which request to service? In which
request do they service? In which order
do they service requests? All of that is
encompassed in this function here, step.
And so, before we go into actually
talking about the implementation, I want
to show you a couple of options here.
And so, this is going to compare option
one, which is FIFO, which is let's just
service every request in the order that
they come in. Really simple algorithm.
And the second is the scan algorithm.
This is by and large how elevators
actually work
uh with some minor caveats, and it's
what we're going to implement here.
And so, I described FIFO. That one is
straightforward. The way that scan works
is that you essentially keep going in
the same direction, sweeping in the same
direction, servicing all requests that
you hit moving in that direction until
you have no more requests or you meet
the uh you you hit the top or the bottom
respectively, and then you turn around
and you keep sweeping in the other
direction again servicing all requests
until that same condition is met. So,
let me show you what this would look
like. Let's imagine that you had request
come in in the order of a hall call for
eight down, a hall call for three up,
and then a cart call or what are we
calling these? Destination calls from
inside of the cab for seven.
So, in the beginning, what you see is
that they were both heading in the same
direction, so SCAN is continuing to
sweep up. FIFO is just trying to go to
the first request, which is eight here.
And so, they keep moving.
That next step, what happens is we
stopped in SCAN because we hit that
seven, which was what was our
destination, right? That seven here.
Even though that was the last request
that came in. We opened the doors, we
let that person get out. We didn't do
that in FIFO cuz we're carrying on to
the first one that came in, the eight
down. Okay? So, let me keep playing.
Now, at this point we get to that eight
down for SCAN. We service it and we
flip. And now we head in the opposite
direction.
We keep scanning all the way until we
get to the bottom where that three is.
We service it, at which point we go idle
because there are no more requests to
service. Now, you can see that SCAN was
much more efficient. So, in our problem
definition where we said that we wanted
to do something semi-efficient, SCAN is
the appropriate thing to do. Now, you
might be thinking to yourself, "Evan,
what the heck? How am I supposed to know
elevator uh algorithms? How am I
supposed to know the name SCAN? Like,
this is a BS interview." Don't worry
about it. You're not expected to know
the name SCAN. Of course not. You're
just expected to be able to reason
around the basic logic that yeah, you
should be heading in the same direction
and not be trying to change directions
all the time. You've been in an elevator
before, right? You know what that's
like. So, we don't need to make it more
complicated really than it is.
The question becomes though, how do we
implement it? And so, let's take the
same approach that we did for elevator
controller, talking about the core logic
and then those edge cases.
And so, starting with the core logic,
let's talk about every condition
that could happen here.
Well, the first is the elevator could
already be idle.
And so, if you are idle with requests,
then you should pick
the direction
toward
the near gosh, typing is hard today,
guys. Nearest request. Okay? So, your
elevator is idle.
You do have requests. Well, you might as
well go towards the closest one. All
right. Straightforward. Nothing
controversial there.
>> [snorts]
>> Um you should also check if we should
stop at the current
floor.
And so, this would either be that it
matches a hall call
or a destination from inside the
elevator.
Right?
And then we have if there are no
requests ahead of us,
then we should reverse. So, if we're
moving down and there are no requests
lower, well, we might as well reverse if
we have other requests. So, none ahead
of us
and other requests pending,
then we should reverse and start heading
in the direction of those requests. All
right? And then the last thing here is
that we should move one floor
in the current direction.
So, we should continue sweeping in that
same direction if we didn't do any of
the things above, we should continue
sweeping in that same direction.
As for edge cases,
uh if there are no requests at all,
then we should set ourselves to idle and
just return, get out of there.
Um
one thing to consider is that like stop
and move, they can't happen in the same
tick.
So, like in the same amount of time, you
can't move to a floor and stop and open.
Like, that would be bending time to some
degree. So, those are two distinct
ticks. Move to the floor, service that
floor, and keep moving. That's going to
be necessary as we think through our
implementation.
Um yeah, so the reverse and same with
the reverse and the move, right? And
reverse
and move, those don't happen in the same
tick. So, I don't know if that's an edge
case.
Yeah, it's not an error condition, but
it is an edge case worth considering.
Anyway,
let's come in here and let's let's
implement this. What was case one? Case
one was there was nothing to do. Um
basically, requests is empty.
There are no requests, and so we set our
direction to idle.
And we return. That one is super easy.
Hopefully, everybody is with me so far.
That one is not controversial.
Case two. Um
maybe if we are already idle,
then we pick a direction.
And so, if our direction is currently
idle,
I don't know why that keeps auto doing
that. Then what we're going to do is we
are going to find the nearest
request to us. We started to see how
these helper functions start to look
with the previous one.
And then we are going to set our
direction, the direction of this
elevator, to
that nearest. So, if the nearest request
that we got, we're going to get its
floor. So, let's say that the request
that we just got was floor
nine. Okay? Now, if that is
above our floor,
then we want to go up.
Otherwise, oh, then we want to go up.
Otherwise, we want to go down. Okay? So,
find the nearest request, get the
request that's closest to us,
see what floor that request is on. If
it's above us, we set our direction to
up. If it's below us, we set our
direction to down.
Okay? Easy enough.
Um what about case three?
So, case three, we can do that we stop
at the current floor. Like, should we
stop at the current floor?
How are we going to define that?
Well, we can define that by just looking
in our set of requests to see if there
is a request for this given floor.
But, it's not just this floor. This is
important. Candidates mess this up all
the time. Um okay, I I got way too
excited about that. But, um
imagine that you are sweeping up here.
Let me reset this guy.
You are maybe sweeping up here.
And you have a down request right here.
You wouldn't stop. Even though you're on
that floor, you would not stop because
this person wants to go down and you are
currently moving up. All right?
And so, we don't just want to set stop
if it's the floor. We want to stop in
the case of a hall call if it's the
floor and the right direction. In the
case of a destination request, we want
to stop no matter what, right? Cuz
destination requests don't care about
the direction.
Um so, how do we do that? We have the
hall call request. Let's make it. We're
just going to check if they're in the
set of requests. It's basically all that
we're doing here.
So, I'm going to create a request object
of
our current floor
and our
type, right? Our pickup type, which we
need to
define. And it's going to be that if our
direction is currently going up,
then that pickup type which we can
service is that pickup up pickup up.
Gosh, I hate that I named it that.
And pickup down, right? Pickup up is is
hard to say.
Destination request.
This is simpler. This is just
the current floor.
I guess we called ours floor, right?
Hopefully,
and then the type is just destination.
Right? Okay. So, those are the two types
of requests that if those are in our set
of requests, then we will stop for them.
And so, let's just check if they're in
our set of requests. So, if our request
contains
the hall call request or if it contains
the destination call request,
uh then we are going to
Well, let me actually do these one at a
time. I think it's probably a little bit
clearer. So, if this is the case, then
we're stopping
and we're going to do requests.remove
him, right? And then same to this one.
And then
requests.remove
him.
So, the removing is like us saying that
we're servicing the request. Maybe that
is admittedly a little confusing. Like,
maybe we should have had an an uh you
know, a stop here in elevator itself
should have exposed
a stop.
In in reality, I don't think it matters
too much. Like, it's up to you. Talk to
your talk to your interviewer. Who
really cares?
Uh I'll I'll do it here. Sure. We're
going to we're going to stop. Stop means
open doors. So, maybe we should have
called it something clearer even, open
doors.
Um
but you get the picture. And then
what else?
I guess at this point we've removed it.
If the requests is empty,
then our direction should now be idle,
right? Is that going to happen in this
step or in next step?
I think it should happen in next step
because we're just stopping here.
And so, in either of those cases, we've
just stopped.
I think this is true,
but I want to return maybe.
So, what I'm going to do is go back to
this. I'm going to do that.
If either of those cases are true,
remove them. It's a no-op if we're
removing something that's not there.
I think we want to return here, right?
The tick is over. We stopped. We said
that we cannot do multiple things on the
same tick. So, at this point, that tick
is over.
I think that's right. Uh I'm sure some
of my astute watchers are noticing some
mistake with that. Let me know, but I
think that checks out doing this here on
the spot. Um and then what was case
four?
Case four
is that we should reverse if there's
nothing ahead.
And so this is the case where we got to
eight.
We got to eight. We could still keep
going up to nine, but we're at the top.
So we might as well just reverse at this
point. And so we need to find that
something is ahead and we can do that
using our handy dandy private helper
method.
And so if there's nothing ahead
then our direction is going to flip.
So if direction currently equals up, it
now equals down.
Otherwise it equals up.
And we return.
Uh and then the last case, the easiest
case, this is just that you're moving in
the direction.
Basically, you're right here.
You're moving
right here. You're moving in the right
direction. There's no reason to stop
yet. Nothing is going on. Your tick is
just to move in another direction or you
know, move another floor. And so if your
direction is currently
up
it's currently up then your floor
[snorts]
plus plus.
Uh else
if direction equals equals down
floor
minus minus.
Okay.
I think this is our scan algorithm.
Let's just check it out. Um again, if
you are idle or if there are no
requests, then you become idle and you
return. That was your tick. There's no
more to do. I'm done. That was my step.
Case two, um pick up direction if I uh
pick a direction if idle.
So we can pick a direction, but just
picking a direction itself isn't a tick.
So that's why I don't return here. We
can pick a direction and then fall
through to actually moving once in that
direction. Moving is one step, right?
Just picking a direction is not a step.
Um so find the nearest request and move
that step. See if we need to stop. Stop
is just is there a hall call to a
service here or a destination request?
If it's a hall call, let's make sure
we're moving in the right direction. If
we stop, then we return. That is a tick.
We were done with it. Or that is a step.
Sorry, I keep saying tick. Um case four,
reverse if there's nothing ahead. If we
reverse, I think we also should not
return, right? Because we've just
reversed. Same logic I just said. We
haven't actually moved. So we'll reverse
and then we'll let case five handle the
actual movement.
Okay. I think I feel decent about that.
As for these helper methods, which one
of these should we do? I'm just going to
paste them both in. I don't want this
video to get too long and they're
ultimately not the most interesting
thing. In your interview, often times
they're comfortable with you even just
not implementing these or just talking
through them.
Um it totally depends on your
interviewer.
Where was I?
Uh
oh, here we go.
Okay. So the find the nearest request,
this is the one here where if we're
idle, we just find the nearest request.
It's easy. Scan all the requests. Find
the closest one. So for all the
requests, take the absolute distance
between your floor
we call this floor not current floor,
between your floor um and the request's
floor and then keep track of that
minimum one, right?
Very similar to the helper method that
we had before.
The has request ahead. Okay? This one is
simply for each request, check is the
direction that you're moving up and the
floor is greater than you? Cool. Or is
the direction that you're heading down
and the floor is less than you? Cool.
Okay. So that's the one that we check
here. Is there any future requests ahead
of us as was not the case right here and
why we ultimately flip directions. All
right, zooming out, that is I probably
can't zoom out far enough actually, but
that is our complete implementation. I
shouldn't say complete, but from an
inter interview's perspective, it's our
complete implementation of elevator and
elevator controller. Request, there's
nothing to implement. It's just some
getters and setters. We implemented a
basic scan algorithm here.
Uh and this is another place where the
strategy pattern could have been used if
you want to allow users to swap the
strategy
um
of how elevators move.
The last open on our delivery framework
is around extensibility.
And so if you are a junior candidate,
maybe even a mid-level candidate and you
got this far, congratulations. This is
probably great. Uh if you've done what
we've done up until this point, you
probably passed the interview. Um if
there is time remaining, your
interviewer might ask you some
extensibility questions. If you're
senior, certainly staff, expect ex-
extensibility questions. These are
follow-ups to check how extensible your
design is and to see whether or not you
can kind of go deep in some of these
core areas.
And so some of the common extensibility
questions for a question like design an
elevator are first about concurrency.
What if multiple hall calls come in at
the same time? What if a hall call comes
in while step is running? That's an
interesting one that we'll spend most of
the time talking about. And then two
easier ones. How would you add priority
floors or an express elevator? How would
you add the ability to cancel a floor
request? Uh so we're going to do all
three of these. In an interview, maybe
you just do one. Maybe you just do two.
Again, I'm being more complete here than
you would be in your interview and
that's why this video might end up going
a little bit longer. Um but let's talk
about this first one. It's by far the
most interesting.
And this is what happens when
two [snorts] users press request
elevator. They press the button from two
different floors, maybe floor nine and
floor five. They both press it at the
exact same time.
What could happen here is two failure
states.
The first failure state is that imagine
there's an idle elevator. They both go
in at the same time. They both select
best elevator and they both get that
idle el- elevator and then we add that
idle elevator to both of their requests.
And this was clearly not the most
efficient thing to do. We should have
added the first request should have gone
to the idle elevator. The second request
should have considered that that
elevator is no longer idle and and
figured out what its best elevator was
respectively.
The second issue is we call add requests
potentially on the same elevator and
then this is a concurrent modification.
And so this is where we are updating the
request set from two separate threads
which if not thread safe data
structures, could overwrite each other.
So we think that we're writing twice but
we actually end up writing once. This is
kind of a common concurrency issue, a
common issue or pattern uh in
multi-threaded systems is that you want
to avoid the concurrent modification of
a given data structure.
So with that in mind, oh I I and one
other thing I I should say that could
happen. In the step function too, we
have the same Where were we?
In the step function, we have the same
issue.
In the step function, we are removing
uh from that request set. And so if we
have requests being added at the same
time the requests are being removed,
another concurrent modification and they
could overwrite each other and it's
going to put us in a state that we don't
expect to be in.
We don't want that.
And so there's two main solutions here.
The first of which is the easiest to
understand um but you know, has some
downsides. And then the second is a
little bit more complex
um but I think the better solution. So
let me show you what they are.
The first one here is that we can just
lock both of those functions. We can
lock the request elevator and the step
function respectively. Put the same lock
around both of them. This is simple and
correct. There will be no concurrent
access to the set at all. But the
trade-off is that they block each other.
So a hall call has to wait uh while step
is running and vice versa. And so when
you acquire a lock, it just means that
all of the you can imagine the function
bodies were here. That's what the dot
dot dot is. The whole function body can
only be executed by a single threaded at
a time and they basically just queue up
and wait for each other. So it'll work.
It'll slow down our system and that's
why it has some downsides, but it's a
decent option.
The other option is a little bit more
fancy.
And it's where we can make add requests
right to a thread safe queue
instead of instead of a set directly.
And then at the start of each tick, let
me copy this in while I'm talking about
it so you guys can get an idea here.
So we have add request ed- add add to
this concurrent safe queue. And then at
the start of each tick, step is going to
drain the queue into the working set.
And so writers only touch the queue
uh and then step only touches the set.
Basically, we have a complete separation
here. Now there's no lock needed. And so
this is this pending requests needs to
be a thread safe data structure. Each
language has a thread safe queue that
you can potentially use.
Uh and then we'll just add the requests.
And then when we get to the steps, we'll
iterate all of our requests and we'll
add them to that set. But this way when
a new add comes in, it touches the
thread safe queue and when our removes
remove, they're removing from the set
which is not the same data structure. So
there is no concurrent modification of
the same data structure. Hopefully
that's pretty clear. Like I said, this
one's simpler and maybe easier to
explain in an interview uh but slows
things down. This one a little bit more
elegant. Both are great answers.
Okay, moving on. Um how would you add a
priority flo- floor? This one is
actually pretty straightforward. How
would you add it? Also, at this point in
the video, maybe pause and ask yourself.
Think about it for a moment. I should
have said that for the other one as
well. Um but there's a couple approaches
to this. Maybe the first thing and I see
this from a lot of candidates is that
you could think, oh let me add a
priority field to the request object and
then I could use a priority queue.
And so I can always go to the one that's
highest in the priority. But this is
going to break all the effort we put
into that scan algorithm, the sweep in
one direction behavior that the elevator
uh class uses. And it's just going to
start jumping around and basically screw
everybody else, right? So there's a
downside there.
A better approach is that you just keep
the standard movement logic for normal
elevators.
But maybe you designate one in our case
of the three elevators as the express
elevator. So you just add like an is
express
to the class. Oh gosh.
This is really not even interesting
enough for me to be typing this for you
guys, but is express
boolean.
You can add that private variable to the
class that can be set on just one of the
elevators.
And then it services just the priority
priority
floors. And so it might have a list of
floors like two, five, and nine, and we
can say those are the priority floors.
And so, now anything any request that's
dispatched to floors two, five, and nine
should go to the express elevator. It's
only running between those three, so
everything's fast. Everything else is
going to the other ones, and and still
using the scan algorithm.
It's generally the best approach there.
All right, last extension.
Uh how would you handle canceling
requests? Super straightforward,
especially considering the way we are
designed right now, we make it really
easy.
It would be as simple as this.
You just add a requests remove request
function, which takes in a request and
removes it from the set. Of course, you
want to lock acquire
if we're still worrying about the
concurrency issues here.
And so, maybe I should do that.
All right.
Release.
But, this extensibility question maybe
is a fun one for junior candidates.
Uh there's not much to it. All right,
you can remove from the set in the same
way that you added. Fortunately, because
our code was already pretty clean, the
removing of the set just means that in
the next uh removing of the request from
the set it means that in the next step,
that's not going to be considered. So,
if all of a sudden we're empty now, we
go idle, all right? If the direction has
changed now, we will change. And so,
some candidates' implementations here
are super messy, and a question like
this is a way for an interviewer to sort
of imply wait, there might be a mess
here. Um but, in our case,
it's pretty straightforward.
All right, that's it, folks. Hopefully,
you found this walk-through valuable. Uh
if you want to try this problem
yourself, head over to hellorust.com and
click on the guided practice for it.
You'll get step-by-step feedback on your
approach through each of these five
phases that we did here. Uh leave some
comments. Let me know what I did wrong.
As always, I'm going to engage in the
comments. Love to hear from you guys. Um
most importantly, best of luck on your
upcoming interviews. You guys are going
to do great. Take care.